je pense que je peux dire merci
avec une ombre
c'est sur ma gauche
là on y va il y a un petit gros arbre
assis là-bas sur un petit point en quelque
sorte oh tu peux voir le reflet dans
l'eau tu vois ça ouais ouais
j'ai ouais ouais
dans quelle direction tu veux que j'aille tout
droit un peu à droite pour qu'on puisse
regarder la pente
comme ça ouais ouais et puis après après
cet arbre on arrive juste en étant
largués au plus bas du niveau de l'eau
oh il y a un  ombre
difficile à dire
ouais d'accord d'accord donc c'est
vous voulez monter et ouvrir oui s'il vous plaît
ici tout droit gardez-vous droit prenez
une petite route ici par opposition au
chemin de terre
oh merde notre
ombre c'était une bonne idée
euh d'
accord je '  J'oublierai qu'un, euh, nous devons en
trouver un autre, un autre sur une autre
ligne, donc nous n'avons pas à voir à quoi
cela ressemble si nous allons dans la
direction opposée, car cela pourrait être
assez loin au sud de nous, nous cachons même cette
route mieux
c'est juste  monte légèrement à une heure
presque au-dessus de la  ridge
c'est peut-être trop grand mais de cette façon je ne suis pas
sûr de
voir de la couleur dans l'eau
ouais ouais il y a beaucoup de
joueurs sur la droite
qui font n'importe quoi ouais euh ouais ouais euh
pas ce que j'avais à l'origine en
tête  mais c'est quand même un coup utilisable
c'est presque on l'a on a on a
qu'en est-il d'essayer de faire un cercle comme sur
ces arbres non ouais qu'est-ce que c'est bien on
doit se faire toucher notre ombre ouais ouais
presque impossible de l'éviter ouais on
doit  attendez les soleils pour la fin
ce que nous pourrions faire
vous voulez de l'eau bien que correct ouais
ouais comme j'aimerais voir une lumière ou un ruisseau
ou une rivière ou
alors peut-être que c'est mieux
comme aller sur le lac sur la gauche oh
nous '  Je serai dans l'ombre et
si j'attendais un peu ouais je
roule dessus alors vas-y ouais
ouais
descends dans le lac pendant que nous le traversons je
ne suis pas sûr que ce sera possible
il n'y a pas beaucoup de longueur à
Je vais tomber mais on peut lui donner un tourbillon Je vais voir des reflets
ouais il y a des reflets
mais ce n'est pas  t énorme pas beaucoup mais
je pense que quand le soleil se couche un peu
plus loin, nous pourrions être mieux
j'ai aussi une route ici qui
en perd un peu
ouais
ouais d'accord eh bien je pense que nous avons du poisson
compris de cette façon nous  Je vais avoir un peu de
couleur et tout avant d'y arriver
ouais même si merde
notre ombre est au large de la tour à
quatre heures ou plus en ce moment d'
accord je dois le voir tu vois ce que nous
pourrions faire, c'est que nous pourrions en quelque sorte le tirer de
cette façon  ouais ouais ouais entrer dans
ça t'aide ouais l'
ombre est toujours là à droite ce
qui est bien, continue juste sur le même
cap ouais c'est pourquoi j'essaie de l'
attraper à travers elle
vois que
nous sommes dans un train à vapeur qui descend  cette
ligne de chemin de fer
une chaîne à vapeur ce serait cool
ouais
deux trois aiguillage à gauche vers le sud
sud à environ
et il y a un reflet de l'eau des
arbres
juste devant vous
sur le cadre
et si vous essayez de
mettre la caméra à côté  au soleil eh bien je
pense que c'est pareil comme de mon
côté à la fin de cette la  ke ici il y a
des trucs rouges et puis le centre pour
le soleil
quel genre d'ombre et d'ombre
ouais je sais mais ça va
ouais aller le long de cette banque de rouge là
-bas juste tomber plus longtemps juste sur le
côté droit de l'
école  les rivières coulent tout de suite
alors
si tu pouvais faire comme un cercle
ces euh sur les arbres à une heure
ouais d'accord tu es l'autre plus gros tu
vois ceux les autres ouais juste ici
juste à côté oui
ouais je laisse le coup  développer vers l'avant
et je reviendrai vers
eux c'est une lumière intéressante sur ce
plan ici parce que c'est un peu rétro
-éclairé et c'est
plus la couleur
bien
regarder le soleil n'est pas tellement une
zone d'ombre mais je pense que c'est un
peu le ciel  sortez comme un nombre d'
accord devrions-nous faire demi-tour nous reviendrons
à cela vous dire ce qui regarde droit
devant nous ici peter ouais
ces arbres pourraient être mieux pour nous maintenant
nous allons bien tête droite ouais ouais de quoi
je parle  à propos
ouais ceux là-bas étaient comme
quelqu'un d'assez élevé '  est sur ma droite à trois heures
euh
continuez à descendre et à tourner autour de
ceux-
ci sur la droite
maintenant nous allons faire passer l'ombre
mais nous allons
maintenant le tir commence à ralentir si
nous maintenons le sp bas
il y a zéro
et puis  vous savez que
nous ferons cette valeur et ensuite nous ferons un
gros plan plus proche d'accord,
donc s'il y a des vibrations sur le plus
gros plan, au moins nous aurons cette valeur
ouais ouais c'est euh 80%
zoomé nous '  je regarde cet arbre juste
à droite ouais ouais ouais
je pense que si nous revenions dans quelques
minutes nous serions probablement mieux seulement à
cause de l'endroit où le soleil ne plaît
plus d'accord
nous ferons un tour de plus ouais
merci
parce que je veux que le lac à l'arrière
un peu de courant d'air sur ces arbres
oh je ne sais pas si c'est tellement notre
courant descendant après le vent qui traverse
la montagne pour être honnête avec vous
parce que je peux vraiment le sentir comme je
Je fais mon tour
c'est pourquoi tu ouais
je n'ai pas vu le lac cette fois
euh arrête juste d'enregistrer  ng à peu près tout de suite
ouais
il y a trop de vert autour de cette chose
ouais c'est un arbre rouge euh
tellement d'autres couleurs ouais ouais quoi de neuf
arrêtez arrêtez d'accord d'
accord
ouais je vois cet arbre mort dans le lit du ruisseau en
quelque sorte aller au-dessus de
qu'aussi bas que vous pouvez puis tourner vers
la droite
voir de quoi vous parlez mais vous
savez
12 heures une heure maintenant celui est
toujours debout ouais ouais lui
-même étranger
ça a l'air bien il y a beaucoup
de continuons à faire le tour  autour de ce
groupe d'arbres,
nous pourrions peut-être nous éloigner d'
eux,
puis nous irons plus loin ouais d'
accord, nous pouvons aller plus loin,
pouvons-nous rester sur le même groupe euh ouais
ouais le même front et euh juste garder
quand nous arrivons
directement au soleil en quelque sorte garder  aussi
bas que possible et j'espère que nous pourrions voir
l'ombre aller en bas pour une diapositive
vers le bas du cadre,
il est ici, espérons-le, ici et tout
ouais peut-être que ce pic descend très
bas, je pourrais incliner un peu vers le haut vers
le
des ombres juste derrière nous  que nous
aurions pu le battre
ouais nous aurions pu le faire
ouais excellent
bien
ouais
si nous
essayons d'essayer cette même trajectoire de vol avec un
objectif à angle plus large, vous allez obtenir l'
ombre que vous venez de manquer,
obtenir une photo grand angle maintenant pendant que nous le pouvons
à partir de là
et puis dès que l'ombre de l'hélicoptère
n'irait pas en gros plan,
je vais évidemment voir l'
ombre de l'hélicoptère dans une
seconde, c'est ouais
ouais je veux dire, c'est juste la
vitesse du mouvement qui change quand
vous êtes large  ou serré
ouais d'accord euh c'est comme un vrai arbre
rouge rouge rouge rouge d'accord on va
s'aligner dessus
parce qu'il n'y a que des rouges autour
oh
pas si drôle
pas de buzzer efficacité du rotor de queue je vais
te tuer vite
je ne mourrai pas pour  une image
nous allons continuer à avoir une ombre
jusqu'à ce que ça s'éloigne ouais ouais d'
accord d'accord eh bien c'est euh d'
accord arrête d'enregistrer viens
à cette montagne à la fin de la
ligue
ouais il a frappé droit pour ça
tu ne roules pas  tu vas
bien ouais je suis là je vais ralentir  en bas
donc où est-ce qu'il y a une bande musulmane
donc
je vais passer du côté sud
de la montagne ouais fais ça ouais
où est la merde bien que l'
ombre de sept heures se lève à neuf heures, elle devrait être
à gauche  côté du cadre ici
rapide
c'est un mélange de verts de foie et pas d'
immigrants
vous pouvez y aller pour toujours ici euh d'
accord nous pourrions nous dégager du lac non
non c'est une bonne lune
ouais ça a l'air intéressant
ouais
parfois avec le rocher qui le traverse
continue
ouais
et c'est  en quelque sorte euh le haut à gauche est
agréable et brumeux et le bas à droite
a plus de contraste, donc il y a
beaucoup de sortes de couches à
oui
la gamme tonale tonale de l'
image est un peu plus uniforme à  le
moment d'
accord
qu'en est-il de l'inclinaison vers le haut oh ouais tu
plaisantes aussi nous avons le lac juste
là
incroyable si nous allions tout droit dorothy
s'il regarde droit c'est toujours assez
bon là-bas dans cette région de la vallée ouais
eh bien ça se passe  surtout  y en
ce moment,
nous devons trouver le genou, même si je
suppose que nous devons monter sur un
côté ombragé de la colline ici
en une seconde, vous allez entrer dans
une très belle lumière pendant une minute d'accord d'
accord  on dirait que le lac
va toujours comme un lac est juste à côté de nous
à gauche
il y a comme une brume à cette altitude
ouais
si nous allions dans l'autre sens
ce qui
me laisse faire un 180 vers la droite d'accord
continuons juste comme ça
je  Je vais juste incliner vers l'horizon juste pour
donner la possibilité d'attendre et d'en sortir
légèrement en remontant l'horizon dans
le plan en quelques secondes,
ce petit virage signifie que je pourrais construire
sans voir directement dans le soleil d'
accord  ça a l'air vraiment brumeux ici ouais ouais
malheureusement quand il fait si chaud
c'est ce que tu obtiens c'est comme ok arrête d'
enregistrer dessus en commençant par ce
défi de l'ombre va être sur notre gauche
ouais je ne suis pas sûr que nous allons peut-être nous
devons  aller à l'autre bout du lac
plutôt que d'aller à la falaise d'autre part  rwise
tu vas ombres allons
continuer tout
droit vers ces euh
arbres morts jusqu'à la plage au bout en
quelque sorte perdu mon orientation vers l'endroit où
ces falaises étaient de toute façon
je pense que nous les falaises sommes probablement
devant nous encore quelques miles a  mile
environ oh d'accord d'accord nous sommes
alors
faites-moi savoir quand arrêter ouais d'accord
pause pause regarde autour de toi maintenant
et tourne à droite oui
tu roules encore tu
roules oui oui tu veux
descendre à la même hauteur que nous  pauvre
et nous voyons presque notre courant descendant ici et
et peut-être même un peu plus loin
vers la droite
et vous garder un peu de fuite comme ça,
je suis toujours en train de faire la queue ici
quantité de friction
et il faut zoomer
ouais  maintenant c'est ça ouais maintenant tête baissée
droite sa tête
je vais prendre de la vitesse
ouais
donc
ça a l'air bien sur le côté aussi ouais ouais
non comme pas juste des arbres qui vont sur le côté
est-ce que ça vibre pour toi non non non
ouais je ne pense pas que c'est moi
Je veux dire que c'est ouais, je ne sais pas
qu'il y a
tellement  beaucoup de choses amusantes se passent avec ce
grand moniteur qui est juste difficile à dire,
regardez ça après ouais ouais
et c'est juste sur la tête
où ces conifères sont à l'
horizon que
si nous rentrons là-bas à l'
extrémité gauche de cet appartement  un peu de la
crête il y avait eu euh